the jail takes a salon owner at the
center of a major lockdown controversy
now free Shelley Luther released from
jail to cheering crowds the Texas
Supreme Court ordering she be let out
after a major uproar from state
officials mrs. Luthor was sent to jail
for seven days after refusing to
apologize for keeping her hair salon
open despite lockdown measures miss
Luthor reacting to her release I just
want to thank all of you who I just
barely met and now you're all my friends
do you mean so much to me and this would
have been nothing without you hmm
Emily you're the lawyer here today so
let me ask you the Texas Supreme Court
says they're looking and reviewing this
case but we know that the lockdown ends
tomorrow Friday so she can go back to
work and the salon will be legally open
but it's is it still possible that she
could have to go back to jail for having
previously broken the law well just to
explain to viewers how this is all
working a lot of the charges that we're
seeing throughout the country are sort
of baked in criminal violations so for
example a San Francisco a man that was
arrested recently for breaking social
distancing they charged him with
trespass and then the underlying charge
was just a violation of public health
and safety right so that's not exactly
criminal in this particular case for her
the reason why she went to jail is just
basically contempt right she refused to
apologize it is a standard example of
the hubris and judicial overreach baked
into our criminal justice system which
frankly isn't just at all most of the
time and the irony to me about this case
is the fact that if she had been charged
with an actual crime and in some cases
some that are perceived as violent to us
like making terroristic threats she
would have been released she wouldn't
have gone to jail because of kovat
concerns so here's the irony you guys
because she broke an ordinance that was
put in place to protect us from the
virus
she was then put into the hot spot where
you contract the virus at an alarmingly
high rate it's like a briar patch where
is the justice in that
it's absolutely ridiculous I'm glad that
this case happened if only to shed light
on the fact that states throughout the
country are sort of disproportionately
applying this and frankly a lot of law
enforcement are at odds whether to
enforce these laws with criminal
measures she's just trying to go to work
so Greg I must say I guess what sticks
in my mind is you shouldn't just be able
to break the law this was an executive
order from a Republican governor and as
Emily said intended to protect us all
from the virus so what do you think yeah
I agree with you I'm feel the same way
about what are those places that you
love sanctuary cities anyway it was also
don't I know it's a Republican governor
but I do believe it's a very very
democratic city and a very very
democratic mayor so nice try on that one
look in these kind of stories visuals
drive coverage and that means extreme
stories tend to be noticed more than
other so this was an extreme kind of
incident it's going to be memorable
about this time about the pandemic do
you remember the woman that owned the
hair salon that's could be memorable but
it's not necessarily indicative of our
law enforcement or American or Americans
or the or the experience this is not
happening a lot it's important that we
see that it's Prada that overreach is
possible we got to check ourselves the
fact is we know the safe bet washing
hands not shaking hands face masks not
gathering in large crowds did did the
brunt of the work in the flattening
we're beginning to wonder if the more
draconian measures policing beach goers
especially out I mean outside shutting
down beaches probably added little to
this and there are studies right now
there's a there's a meta-study
analysis of 14 studies that show that
that made that casual short interactions
are not spread are not the main spreader
of this and that if you could just
practice the social distancing we're
gonna have to so they're draconian
measures we're gonna have to let go Dana
the White House said today they're not
going to follow some CDC guidelines
and what we know is that they want to
get things open I think everybody wants
things open but safely and so the
question then arises if we go in that
direction
should they be ignoring the fact that so
many states in fact have a rising number
of cases even as they're reopening well
it's possible that the CDC guidelines
might have been too strict or too
stringent based on the new information
that they have there's a new data point
every hour on the coronavirus Greg just
pointed out a good one about being
outside or now there's questions about
is it dangerous to wear a mask while
you're exercising I mean every single
day you find out something new so I
think that maybe that story's a little
bit overwritten that the White House is
not using those particular guidelines
obviously we're using guidelines and I
haven't really want to say that the
woman in Dallas as Greg said I'll always
remember where where I was when I saw
that woman you really stick up for her
principles and to see her relief and I
admire it
I really do I do think it's quite
amazing that on one day you had her
release from jail you had Michael Flynn
case drop from the Justice Department
and you had the Bridgegate case be
thrown out by the Supreme Court so those
two people are in I said an amazing day
for people who were accused of things
that is true and so Jesse just to finish
up here I think people in this country
admire civil disobedience people
standing up for what they see is right
principle but I think you also have to
accept the consequences then you know in
the Martin Luther King jr. tradition if
you get sent to jail you go to jail and
you don't put other people in harm's way
how does that fit with this history she
was willing to go to jail and she went
to jail for a certain amount of time so
I don't see anything wrong with that
listen one if you go to a barber shop
and you wash your hands before going
into the barber shop and the barber
washes his hands and you two are the
only one in the barber shop and you guys
are both wearing masks and you get a
trim and then you pay with a credit card
I don't think you're gonna spread
coronavirus especially if you have the
door or a win
open let's just be honest about this